هبدا من اوكرانيا تحديدا من معارك الدائره
حاليا في سوليدار حيث تتضاربوا التصريحات
حول السيطره الروسيه الكامله عليها حتى
الان ففي الوقت الذي اكد فيه الكرملين ان
الهجوم على دنيا اسك يتواصلوا بنجاح قالت
اوكرانيا وعلى لسان نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني كان مليار ان الجيش يقاتل من
اجل سوليدار لكنه وصفه الوضع بالصعب على
الارض في ظل معارك هي الاشرس مع قوه
الروسيه بحسب وصفهها واضافت ان الجنود
الاوكرانيين يقاتلون من دون توقف ورغم
انها لن تشكل نقطه تحول في الحرب الا ان
سقوط السوليدار في روسيا بعد اشهر من
الدفاع الاوكراني سيكون علامه فارغه في
ساحه المعركه هو سيوفر للقوات الروسيه
نقطه انطلاقا استراتيجيا لجهودها من اجل
تطويق مدينه باخم مرتب وبحسب الماليه
فانوس تحشد هاتيها في المدينه حيث ارتفع
عدد الوحدات العسكريه الروسيه في المدينه
من 250 الى 280 في اسبوع واحد
وقالت ان الوضع بات يشبه المذبحات ووفقا
لمسؤولين اوكراني اخر ان القتال وصل ذروته
على الجبهه الشرقيه حيث يحاول الروس
محاصره القوات الاوكرانيه ياتي كل ذلك وسط
مخاوف من هجوم المحتمل من بيلاروسيا حليفه
موسكو القديمه شمال اوكرانيا هذا واكدت
صحيفه هرست جورنال ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تتكبدت خسائر فادحه في المعارك قرب مخمد
وارجحت الصحيفه نقلا عن قائد عسكريا
اوكراني امكانيات التراجعي في حال استمرار
الوضعي على حاله
[موسيقى]
متابعه لما يجري على او في الوضع
الميدانيه ينضم الى المكياج الصحفي محمد
البابا من دونيتس مراسله العربيه رائد
الاخضر
سابدا معك من موسكو مع ايضا كاتيا تعمي
مراسله العربيه اهلا بكم معنا سابدا مع
رائد لنعرف من هو بالضبط ماذا يجري في
دونياسك اهم تطورات الميدانيه والعسكريه
هناك تفضل رائد
ميسون بالفعل يعني مع
ارك عنف والقذف المتبادل ما بين الطرفين
هنا في دانيت في المدينه حيث تقصف المدينه
منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر وكانها ضربات
انتقاميه للتقدم الروسي في محور سوليدار
بالفعل اضافه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
القوات تسيطر القوات روسيا على المحور
الشمالي والشرقي من مدينه
كباريه تجري وسط المدينه وفي مناطق متفرقه
منها الغربيه اما القوات باجنر فعلى لسان
قائدها اكدت انها
سيطر ضد المدينه وانها قضت على
اكثر من 100 جندي اوكرانيا
جيوب المدينه رفضوا الاستسلام ااه بالفعل
هناك معارك ضاريه في المحور الغربي من
المدينه حيث تشير بعض المصادر الى اندادات
اوكرانيه وصلت للقوات المتمركز في غرب
مدينه سلدار لكن الاله العسكريه الروسيه
ثقيله نتحدث عن المدافع
والصواريخ تقصد باستمرار همم همم
قد تصل الى ذلك المحور وتقصف قواعد عسكريه
او نقاط رياضيه للاتصال ما بين المقاتلين
على الجبهات وما بين الطرف اخر همم كقياده
اوكرانيه همم حتى الجانبيه
الزميل محمد البابا ايضا وجهه النظر
الاوكرانيه وما هي ابرز تصريحات من قبل
المؤسسه العسكريه والقوات الاوكرانيه محمد
ماذا تتحدث القوات او الدفاع الاوكرانيه
عن موضوع سوليدار هل سقطت بيد روسيا ام
بعد
يعني
حرس الحدود الاوكراني نشر بيان قبل حوالي
ساعه من الان اكد ان قوته تقوم بالرد
وتتقدم وبدات تشتبك عند الاتراك الشرقيه
والشماليه حيث دخلت واصبحت يعني يمكن
القول ان ان بلده اصبحت يعني متداخله هناك
مناطق لا تسيطر عليها القوات الاوكرانيه
وتنتشر فيها وايضا هناك مناطق استطاعت
القوات الروسيه
الدخول اليها هناك اشتباكات عنيفه الجيش
الاردني
وايضا من بلده الكريسما هو بتلك البلديه
هناك تجمعات القوات القوات الجيش
الاوكراني بدا الجيش الاوكراني ونقل
المدفعيات يعني ثقيله ومن نوع هاوس الى
ذلك الى ذلك المحور لدار الخطوط القوات
الروسيه فكانما قالت
يعني نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان
المعارك ضاريه جدا ويعني الجيش الاوكراني
حتى هذه اللحظه لا يزال يقاتل لا يزال
ان يعني ستبقى قوته وستبقى سوريات الجيش
الاوكراني ولكن كما كما ذكر رائد الهجوم
الكبير والعنيف وحتى يمكن القول يعني بحسب
شهود عيان من مناطق مجاوره اصوات
الاشتباكات والمدافع لا تتوقف ولا لحظه في
تلك المنطقه من الطرفين هناك يعني قصص
متبادل بشكل عنيف من الطرفين الجيش
الاوكراني يكثر خطوط الامداد للجيش الروسي
الجيش الروسي يكثر خطوط الامداد الجيش
الروسي كما يمكن الكون ان هذه يعني هذه
اشبع به مثل معركه نهائيه بين الطرفين
يفعى الطرفين لتحقيق الانتصار على الاخر
الجيش الروسي وضع عقول ثقاله بحسب معلومات
يعني ذكرها انه في تلك المحور تم حشر ما
يزيد عن 30,000 جندي على ضخمه الشرقيه
والجنوبيه واللي احكام السيطره على
الاداره والتقدم باتجاه بعض
اوكرانيه في مخمل ليبدا بعد الهجوم على
بعض
ساذهب الان الى موسكو مع ليلتنا كاتيا
كاتيا بالنسبه لتغيير في القياده العسكريه
الروسيه ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل وما هي
حيثياتها
مرحبا بك ميسون بالفعل كان قد اعلنا وزير
الدفاع الروسي تغييرات تغيير القائد قائد
العمليات العسكريه في العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا كان قد اعلن يوم امس ان ااه ان
ان النائب صريف كان هو سيكون القائد سوري
كان هو سيكون نائبا للقائد
الذي هو سيقود الان العمليات وطبعا برر
برره الدفاع الروسيه هذا هذه التغيرات
بانها تريد برفع مستوى العمليات العسكريه
هناك وانها الحاجه الان هناك ان يكون على
المستوى الرفيع من القياده لاداره
العمليات وبالاخص بعد الدخول الى مدينه
سوليدار ومن بعدها طبعا كما تحدث البعد ان
هناك همم من بعث في لندن سيتم المحاوله
الاستيلاء على ضخمود بشكل كامل لذلك برر
بان الحاجه الان والارض العمليات على
الارض هي بحاجه الى ان يكون على المستوى
الرفيع من همم من هذا وبلاخص ان القائد
الجديد هو الثاني بالهرم العسكري في
الروسيا وبحاجه للتنسيق الكبير بين القوات
الاربعه لنلاحظ ان طبعا هذا التغيير هو
الرابع في لقائد العمليات العسكريه في ال-
اا في اوكرانيا هو الشخص الرابع ثلثا لم
يكن لم يزل او لم ااه يكن الا ثلاثه اشهر
في هذا المنصب ولكن لم يتم ابعاده بشكل
كائن كامل هو سيكون نائب لقائد العمليات
هناك اربع عشان اربع من الجنانيرات او
القاده الكبار سيقودون الان العمليات هناك
في اوكرانيا ميسون سنعود الى زميلنا قراءه
الاخبار من دونيس بالنسبه للوضع الانساني
رائد كيف يمكن ان نصفه وهل هناك همم حاله
نصوح من المناطق التي تتكثف فيها
الاشتباكات العسكريه
اشاره هامه جدا ميسون بالفعل هناك حملت
نزوح كبيره من مدينه دانيت حيث اقامتنا
حيث ان كثير من سكان هذه المدينه توجهوا
الى المناطق الجنوبيه حيث مريوبلنبات
الاكثر امنا لكن
على سيفه ان
مسؤوليه حقوق الانسان عند الجانب الروسي
والمسؤولي حقوق الانسان ايضا عند الجانب
الاوكراني يتواصلون ويقرون
باجراء عمليات تبديل جديده في كل يوم او
ثلاثه تتم عمليه تبديل
للاسرى من المتوقع في اليومين القادمين ان
تكون هناك ايضا عمليه جديده لاستبدال
الاسرى بين الطرفين ك
ما ان الفتح ممرات امنه للمواطنين
العالقين في المناطق الساخنه مثل سوليدار
وسيفه
احد ما لان باقي هي همم الهدف الرئيس
للقوات الرئيسيه حيث انها اصبحت
تقريبا شبه مطلقه من الناحيه ال والشماليه
والشرقيه ويعني يرى الجيش الروسي
بانه سيتقدم نحو ال بلدات في افراح مدينه
باكو من اجل بحر الجيش الاوكراني الى
الخلف من الناحيه الغربيه
الصوت من المصدر اشكر زميلنا رائد الاخضر
من دونياسكا الصحفي محمد البابا من كاف
وزميلتنا كاتيا تومي مراسلت العربيه من
موسكو شكرا لكم